hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about um
when should we start speaking in a
language and i refer specific to this
concept that we need to speak from day
one we need to speak early in order to
learn a language that this is somehow
a shortcut
a secret to
learning languages more quickly
i mentioned this because we had a
and still have an interesting thread at
our forum at link
on the subject of when we should start
speaking and it started with one of our
members who is a great contributor to
link evgeny who has created countless
wonderful lessons for learning russian
in our library and who's a very
experienced teacher and he says he gets
annoyed
at those students who feel they can just
talk the rate of fluency and don't put
the effort into listening and reading
and building up their vocabulary and
learning the grammar and so forth and so
on
and this sparked a lively debate and
some people agreeing with them some
people not
i of course agree with evgeny i'm not a
teacher so i'm not bothered by
people who won't put the effort into
learning the language we just somehow
think they can magically
talk their way to fluency
but i speak more as a learner
and i'm trying to remember the points
that i had made
basically summarizing the discussion
there's three things wrong with this
idea of you know speak from day one
speak my way to fluency
the first one is that it's not very
practical
if you have no words and if you don't
understand what the other person is
saying you can't say very much
so
speaking from day one means either
having a very
patient
person who's going to accommodate you
while you essentially have
nothing to say and don't understand what
they're saying
or paying for a teacher
most people who study a language are not
in the country
so they're somewhere else so they would
have to i guess get a teacher or
you know try and find some native
speakers who are going to spend time
with you but realistically how do you
feel if someone comes up to you who can
barely speak english and says i want to
speak to you in english
i quite frankly unless this is a close
friend or unless they're paying me
i'm not going to spend much time with
them maybe i'll be polite for a couple
of minutes but nothing much beyond that
uh
if we are in a country where we don't
speak the language we're better off to
use english for a practical
for practical reasons so therefore i
think it's not realistic to expect that
you can speak from day one
uh
the second thing is that it is
irrelevant to the final outcome in terms
of if our goal is to achieve fluency
whether we speak from day one day 10 day
50 it doesn't matter in my experience i
like to start speaking when i have
something to say in other words when i
have enough words that i can i can
actually have a meaningful and therefore
enjoyable
uh and i have seen all kinds of examples
uh when i lived in japan for example of
people who had a few phrases
uh you know hello goodbye you know dame
no good
utsugushi beautiful or subarashi or
konnichiwa and that's all they ever
learned
those people who became fluent in the
language put the effort into
listening reading building vocabulary
studying you know books i mean it takes
work
and just kind of hoping that you can
converse your way to fluency i think is
therefore a unrealistic b irrelevant to
the final outcome
and the third thing is
that
by encouraging people to think that they
can just talk the rate of fluency it it
hides the fact that it actually is a
fair amount of work to achieve fluency
in my own experience like i read
thousands hundreds of thousands of words
and i listen to most of that now i enjoy
doing that and that's the other thing
uh a lot of the sort of
passive learning if you want is for many
people
almost the goal of their learning it's
extremely enjoyable we like to watch
movies in french or japanese or read
you know or watch korean drama
or
you know even to be able to understand
the conversation
uh
this this ability to
understand what's going on in other
words to have the vocabulary and to
build up on comprehension
is
rewarding it's extremely rewarding and
it is the precondition for fluency you
can't become fluent if you don't
understand what other people are saying
to you so i mentioned this first of all
uh because of the
uh discussion we had on our forum and
also because it relates to the 90-day
challenge that i'm doing in korea and
people have asked me
you know because i'm going to be doing
videos
uh both in english and korean talking
about what i do how i'm learning how i
spend my time during the day and also
talking to korean people when the
opportunity is there
but there's no obligation for other
people to do this
people can take the 90-day challenge
commit to spending time
with the language reading and listening
and they can talk as little or as much
as they want and they certainly have no
obligation to produce a video for other
people to see
however i will say
that
uh in our path to fluency eventually we
have to talk a lot you cannot become
fluent you cannot convert your passive
knowledge of the language into fluency
unless you expose yourself to a lot of
situations where you are speaking but
that comes later on but one of the very
useful things to do is to create videos
on youtube and keep them private you
don't have to publicize them and then
you can
as you watch yourself speak you become
very much aware of where your mistakes
are and what you need to work on to
improve so
you know there's a lot of different
strategies you can use to get yourself
to where uh you know you can speak well
but
speaking from day one is not one of them
so
insofar as my own activities now in
korean
uh i have already spent
you know probably six seven eight months
on average an hour a day so whatever
that is 150 200 hours
on korean so i'm not starting from
scratch and yet when i go to speak to
people
you know if i see some korean speakers
in vancouver i will not pass up the uh
pass up the opportunity but i go to them
more to show off than anything else
because i don't understand what they're
saying back to me very well i haven't
been in very many practical situations
of communicating occasionally when i
play golf with my friend mr choi will
speak in korean i don't understand much
of what he's saying he has an accent
that's another issue
uh
you know i have like when i was really
into my career six seven years ago i did
have some meetings
with the president of a local korean
newspaper and we were half an english
half in korean but my korean has
since declined so my strategy here again
is i've got to get my korean up to a
level where i can understand what people
are saying and so the initial 90 days
okay the initial 15 to
30 days is going to be heavily focused
on input and thereafter i will step up
the speaking and i intend also to do
more writing which i haven't done in the
past so i'm tomorrow which is the first
day of my 90-day challenge i'm going to
go to a korean bookstore here in town
and i'm going to buy a book which
hopefully which korean children use
to learn to write the hangul
because i'm going to have to write it if
i'm going to pass this
topic exam sometime in april when i
intend to go to
go to korea but in any case i just
wanted to mention that that at least
from my perspective
you start speaking when you feel like
speaking there's no obligation if you
want to try to speak if the opportunity
is there you want to try it what you've
learned do so but if you don't have that
opportunity and you're not going to
rearrange your social life just to
create that opportunity
it's not a problem
many people have a few phrases that's
all they ever learn and other people who
don't use those phrases but start
speaking a month or six months later
they may end up with an even higher
level like it's largely irrelevant so
there i i wanted to express these views
and again tomorrow i start my korean